it was random bro oh no it just said
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right guys before we get into the
Juicy Juice you need to shut up and
listen to what we have to say listen
well yeah yeah right so the Log Cabin
tour is in full swing full effect we
drop our first show in Leeds on Thursday
we do we do following this Thursday guys
following that show we have the after
party we do the first half of the first
official the first official official Log
Cabin after party with your boys we're
gonna be in we're gonna be in the Dance
Floor holding wines and shaking stuff
that's fast we're gonna be in there the
warehouse leads let's go Warehouse in
Leeds guys so if you live north of
England okay even if you live Midlands
yeah head on over to the warehouse in
Leeds get your tickets guys the link is
in the description the link is in the
bio box the link is linking Fox is
everywhere links us you've got facts the
link is Lincoln link us but I'm going to
be touching toes shaking stuff I'm going
to be grips into shaking stuff looking
back at it and covering some
so if you're trying to see it and grips
man come through come through yeah same
with you guys in London if you live
South of the Border guys you London
dance
head on over to x-o-y-o on the 11th
Thursday again we're turning up cheeks
will be clapped
shoulders will be shaking the little
Shimmy Shimmy the drinks will be
drinking your boys will be merely
rocking the Millies will be rocking bro
yeah and it's gonna be a Vibe so come
with us turn up have some fun
I can't wait I can't wait guys we're
gonna be tipsy and chatting and dancing
I actually can't wait so make sure guys
make sure you don't miss out the
warehouse leads and x a while London
please don't miss out links are in the
descriptions links are everywhere you
need to know it's gonna be a Vibe we're
going to be there rem's gonna be there
Ellis is going to be there so make sure
you guys are there everyone's going to
be there right let's get into the
episode IG question what we got IG
question of the week guys the last few
weeks have been they've been hitting and
I'm Gonna Keep it going so the IG
question of the week this week was
what's something you've done that you
can't bring yourself to tell anyone
about
Jesus okay yeah cool you guys with me
something you've done you don't want
anyone to find out that you can't tell
it you can't bring yourself to tell
anyone about oh God okay cool anyone
cool cool cool cool cool
I was the one who told my dad's
girlfriend he was cheating on her
what's wrong with you
thus
that's taken
broke our stuff to another level we're
broken
that's taking bro code my own son
nudes to my 79 year old neighbor he paid
200 each pick
would you yeah facts would you rip
Ellis
and this is a liar
200 per picker pick and you ask him how
many picks do you need and he said all
of it as many as you want one Bill's a
pop
I've got to be fair actually yeah
you can pop them every day
there you go that's that's red sorted
true that's a lifestyle saw it
are you
I saved I lost the 250 I'll be cheeky
sharp would you do it for two
I would ask for 250 and BT answer the
question
be cheeky
shut up I will show me how much you're
worth five percent for 250 I said plus
size
is it plus size in it if you want to get
cheeky
we could get cheeky
put science in it
I can't receive a DM or a message from a
79 I was saying that bro I would love
that to turn around on you because I'll
be sending him all the cheeky stuff for
my humble two starting yeah because
you're saying rummy 250 let's get cheeky
and he said all right put something in
there and they were like no no all right
two's fine and you say no no no no no no
no
oh [__] that's jokes
I once behind a tree a dog comes over
and the owner thinks it's the dog she
picks it up
that
I wouldn't sleep
if you're the dog owner no bro if I'm if
I'm the if you're said the person behind
the tree yeah if I'm the one who did it
and I watch someone else do that I
wouldn't sleep why because it's like
they're really God just doesn't protect
us from anything
[Laughter]
he literally left it all on phone
anyone do what they want and get away
with it God really doesn't protect
anything
hilarious oh livid I call in sick once a
month and pretend to go to work in the
morning and have a me day
I mean there's only so many times you
can get away with that though
once a month I used to have it I used to
you can get away I know the corporate
ladder bro you can get away with 10 in a
year 10 10 incidences okay in a year
okay
um and you get like a
I think I used to get like a verbal
warning
on like number five on incident number
five answer number five the black
brother yeah you're taking this is
number five you've got five more but
we're on to you yeah and I'm like come
on and these are incidences yeah not
days okay so you stretch it out and you
can sign yourself off for a week
best believe I was off 10 weeks a year I
swear 100 because I would only intend on
taking one day okay and then you realize
why am I going back tomorrow if I ask
because it turns out a sprained ankle
doesn't heal yeah that turns out yeah
yeah I have to I have to be able to poop
the whole time the worst thing is though
is when you have to spread it out you
can't be just doing it every month okay
so you have to be tactical with it
um so the big ones was when I actually
got ill yeah or actually hurt myself oh
because I remember I did a bumped a week
one time and then on the Friday yeah I
went to jiu jitsu
buggered my neck yeah I couldn't move my
head the boy who cried wolf The Boy Who
Cried Wolfram I drove into work shaking
so please I can't make it I'm thinking I
don't know what I'm gonna do yeah
because I can't call the sick again yeah
because they'll be like swear down how
did you even hurt yourself you were off
sick how did you hurt your neck
so I had to firm it with a bus up next I
was livid I was thinking I'm never
calling sick fake again yeah you are
definitely the boy who cried wolf bro
but then I did it the next month
I did it every other month
I couldn't stand it in there I bet you
couldn't bro all right next one I
fantasize about sleeping with my wife's
sister
fantasize yeah I mean that doesn't
surprise I mean it surprises me a little
bit but like I can imagine like
certain relationships
because this is the way I see it like
I think about this a lot this is a bit
harsh okay that's what I think about a
lot okay I'm intrigued if I'm I'm
bearing in mind I'm not staying I'm not
I'm not punching down I'm not saying
this because I think I'm here I'm saying
this just as the way I see the universe
okay
if I'm a six
if I'm a five average yeah yeah if I'm a
five Average Joe yeah and my Lane is
fives and a pattern of five
I know she's a five just because I'm a
five and she's a five doesn't think
doesn't mean I think I'm a 10 and she's
a 10. okay so I love her don't get me
wrong I love her but she's a five if her
sisters are seven
I know she's out my league yeah yeah
yeah she's around my house every three
days
yeah and we Giggle and we drink yeah
yeah
funny yeah and she knows she thinks I'm
funny she knows when I get a haircut
yeah yeah she's found out I'm size 11 I
said yeah do you know what I mean yeah
yeah yeah I think you can pause yeah I
don't think he actually thinks she's
down and she's fine yeah she wouldn't
die yeah she would do it she wouldn't
dare you're deluded you're deluded and
you get loss of it and then you
fantasize about banging your sister a
lot yeah that's how these things spiral
damn damn that's that's that's a good
Insight that's good Insight all right
run it back what's this what's something
you've done that you can't bring
yourself to tell anyone about I've only
been with married men
I've only been with married men
if I can you imagine being her therapist
and you're married
I dropped my pen
I'll wipe the wife
I've ripped my glasses out so you were
safe Let's Fold it everything like these
with the notepad here yeah I would hear
that
and I would literally just wipe the
corners of my mouth and you should hit
me like
oh Jesus
Christ married men you say I only bang
married men and she's looking at you
looking at you deep deep in your Soul
Fam I'd be thinking how deep is a
malpractice suit anyway fat yeah what's
it really what it gonna do what are they
going we're short on therapists facts
this is Dr Klein slap on the wrist kind
of thing no one else has got to know but
me and her
that's hilarious
I'll drop my bed immediately immediately
I I would be thinking this this game's
not for me bro this job's not for me bro
it's tantalizing I could eat what you
mean
married man
since when bro so when did you lose it
when'd you lose that v card only married
men yeah she's yeah you're a freak she's
got experience yeah you're a freak
that's exactly yeah yeah I'm right in my
name yes freak freakily
laughs
freak a leak bro
wow oh my days that's hilarious
ah
went through my friend's phone and saw a
video of her stepdad giving her mum head
in her phone
this is where did she find that or did
she take it questions bro questions I
don't have the answers yeah
you can't see stuff like that pissed on
my ex's hand when he fingered me
that's disgusting
I'm great at stealing anything when I
need to
wow stealing anything when I need to
when push comes the sun it's mine
flipping oh that's hilarious oh theft
gets your blood going doesn't it man
when I was 14. left gets your blood
going when I was a little teenager yeah
me and Primark were like this
like this okay I never stepped up to
close oh that's that that's Brad larsony
I remember I bumped into problem
that's too scary for me I was on the
sweets and lucozades
I called ribena yeah I'm having that
a little can slide in my pocket pocket
asked me all day
wine gums yeah I couldn't get enough
yeah I stole sweet yeah yeah I stole
sweets massive primer not on the clothes
in broad daylight yeah put on the
clothes snap the target that's I don't
have that level of confidence
because if the security guy stops you
it's long I don't know because I was up
in doing a corner shot there's no
security yeah yeah I just need to not
turn up here again true but one time a
lady chased me out one stop no [__]
chased me out tell me bro me and my boy
Rob he was bait with it he couldn't get
enough bro he's addicted to the lights
oh African brother like you just putting
that yeah yeah just like you in a casino
he couldn't get enough bro he didn't
know how to hold back
but I said African brother like you
well he couldn't get enough bro once he
got away with it once I needed more yeah
adrenaline yeah yeah [__] is so good
sorry bro I was doing it that calculated
once I know I can get away with I'm not
taking any more bro yeah if it's one can
and one sweet that's where we'll wrap
yeah and maybe if there's only if
they're low on staff she's not paying
attention maybe two sweets bro
he went in there and I need to buy
something now and again of course this
is my local ah yes Steven from your
local speak bro this is my local I don't
want to do them dirty like that I'm
gonna buy something yeah I'm achieve
some stuff and I'm gonna buy some [__]
balance so fam little bang pocket wine
gums bang pocket I'm getting some
Doritos and I'm paying like a man yeah
and you know when they have that
spherical yeah mirror you can see her
she can see around what's going on yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I was paying la dee
Dash I seen her just looking she wasn't
looking at me I seen her just looking up
I looked up he was having a field day
Sam he was in the aisle just no and he
[__] yeah he could fight overflow him
bro oh poor that's poor form fam I
looked up and my heart was racing clock
that you were like an accomplice nah I
was started to walk out and she said
both of you stop right there
I thought that that's the evidence in
someone's [__] front garden a [__]
dipped she said I know who you are don't
come back
oh I went to shake it but it was
giggling he was [__] giggling and it
was my local yeah I was gonna say hey I
still know what shop it was till now bro
down away from my mom's bro I was like
what's wrong with you um bro you're
talking about yeah you've been there bro
you don't want to stop bro yeah I know
exactly so what's wrong with you guys
um Master sharp man we got away with it
I said no we didn't bro I can't go back
so we got away we've got a wave that's
your stuff he took everything he took
everything he went down to nothing
because he's he's a villain as well
because he was like he's the kind of guy
I wish he would catch me because he'll
just pump her up he was crazy but no he
wouldn't
I'm not a liar
he'll just pump her up he was tapped bro
oh wow he couldn't get enough of it oh
wow once you've got a taste of crime he
wanted the whole he won the whole
banquet yeah yeah he wanted the whole
thing oh man yeah next thing he was shot
in weed next thing he was yeah he was
bro he was a criminal and he was
obsessed with G-Unit that's all I
remember about him
well you know he he was the only brother
that paid for them G-Unit kicks
it didn't make sense bro oh my God he
would shut up about 50 cents
he will show up about it
it was random bro oh no it just said
[Laughter]
bro slow down
you're walking from RE to arm I would
say it's [__] jarring bro
that's hilarious oh [__] oh Jesus that
was hilarious right what's something
you've done that you can't bring
yourself to tell anyone about
I pursued these triplets and was
rejected by all of them
yeah and all of them said nah bro
that that that that would do something
to your confidence fam and I would love
to be one of the twins in that
conversation that evening
[Music]
um
when twin number two yeah says oh
triplet number two says bro you'll never
believe who tried to move to today
Sally McGarvey bro
she tried to move to me today she tried
to move to me as well and children
number three is Vex yeah and then he
comes back the next day like fast
bro
I can prove it yeah
yeah we're not begging Oh my days that's
hilarious
I wrote One Direction fan fiction bro
damn
ass bro crazy you know I found out late
in life
I swear someone couldn't cooperate This
I Swear down Twilight is like Harry
Potter fan fiction never heard of that
Twilight is some kind of fan fiction
didn't know that no everyone's saying
it's it's wrong oh it's [__] yeah
it's just load of bollocks that's
probably uh as much [__]
it's as much [__] as who has friggin
uh broccoli
um man-made broccoli yeah oh yeah that
was wild but did it address it as a
rumor yeah it was a rumor yeah okay
that's bad it was a rumor yeah it's a
bunch of [__]
all right at least acknowledge is a
rumor I got lost in the rumor jokes got
pregnant on purpose to see if he would
choose me or he's Wife and Kids he
obviously chose her
obvious
ly he obviously chose her he chose her
but that's a thing as well like
what is this bring your kids to one day
that scared me fast it sounded like a
horror movie I'm not going to lie my
heart left me for a second bro that was
scary oh that was terrifying
um but yeah
if he's got a wife and kids
sighting and kid doesn't Trump wife and
kids facts obviously he chose them on
what planet do you think he's gonna
choose you oh the fact that she said
obviously is mad
when I was a kid I tried I tried on my
mom's bras and [__] I still don't know
why
that's a bit nuts ah I mean is it I used
to try mom's shoes on
did you heels bro facts I didn't
understand it's just fascinating to me
did you rap yeah I told him to call my
mom's heels before yeah yeah stockings
yeah heels I mean I don't know about
stockings that that was wild
just me and I'm playing I'm playing I'm
just talking to seals laughs
Alice what have you tried on at least
the only thing I've done is literally
like Joe if you need to go in the garden
or something near his shoes mum's bang
that's it I've not actually gone and
modeled in the mirror or anything I
didn't model in the mirror bro I was
just like high heels are fascinating to
me so you started yours you you walk
down the hall and back now just my mom's
room I couldn't make it to the hall but
I was clunking around I wasn't making it
to the hall bro just took him out the
Wardrobe yeah
it's difficult yeah I've got my day I've
never done that bras
craps whatever nothing like that nothing
that's crazy
um I tried sucking my own dick and
succeeded oh dear family
I've never tried that but nothing I'm
nah to be fair when I was like I'm not
gonna lie bro it was like when I was
like 11 and I heard about that Marilyn
Manson thing oh you see he took out a
rib cage
took out like two ribs so he could suck
himself off
you have to try when you hear that room
and you're like how hard is it no pun
intended facts and then you try and you
just fail and you get on with your day
no did you get on with your day yeah
thanks but I couldn't reach
I can reach bro if I could it might be a
different story
but I can't but at the same time I
couldn't feel tall in my mouth even if
it's my I couldn't feel tall on my
tongue but I don't think as an 11 12 or
like pre-teen kid that's your first
thought that I've got tall in my mouth
yeah do you know what I mean because I
was yeah I've got tall in my mouth yeah
whereas it's the same as a finger yeah
it's just a [__] appendix and it's in
my mouth I don't care yeah I could be
sucking my phone yeah and it wouldn't
get good to me either
you know what I mean it wouldn't be
Scentsy like that
yeah it just feels like touching it
wouldn't feel good
would you actually neck yourself if you
could no no I mean like if you oh do you
think you would neck yourself
now I wouldn't of like because I think
as a kid like I'm saying if I reached
and it touched my tongue it wouldn't get
good to me so I have no reason to carry
on sucking it do I mean like that's just
Madness because what am I doing I don't
suck anything else so why am I just
continuing to do this true true true
there's no like
um transferable skills towards it yeah
yeah bro so yeah no yeah no way okay
there's jokes man said I'm not gonna lie
when I'm alone I take all my clothes off
to eat my chicken wings that's flipping
crazy talk
all my clothes that's do you know how
banging chicken wings have to be for me
to get undressed it has to be bagging
and slippery yeah they need to be
smothered inside
and I
and I need to be naked and just the
apron facts yeah because I'm going
straight in the shower I have to be
slippery they have to be you know the
ones when you're trying to break the
wing apart yeah the knuckle slits off
your fingers facts yeah yeah straight to
the toilet and straight in the shower
that's crazy talk you have you have to
love Wings bro [__] you have to love
wings that's that's something else
I changed my own name and my phone to my
ex's name and text myself to feel like
it's him again
that's down bad bro
to feel like it's him again
I stalked my own boyfriend in a wig to
watch him go on dates
what's wrong with these women bro how
can you love someone this much bro
you know I couldn't in a way
because I know it's you yeah
don't dip your head and hide face me
face me and I'm drapes enough you've
caught me fine but I'm drapes it off
each other yeah and I better not see
like The netting under it needs to be
freelance I can't see that but there's
much preparation oh [__] I can't see the
baby has slicks little cane Road
if it's Kane Road I'm crazy I'm applying
for something
I'm applying for satin on you bro
because you need help yeah you need
medicinal help
those jokes a girl a girl told me my nut
wasn't tasting as fresh as it used to be
I had to confirm myself
oh bro no I didn't think it was going to
spin that way it spun that way now why
would you say that to me
no I'm saying to go oh yeah facts why
would you say that to me it's not
tasting it's not tasting as like
freshers
what you've been eating bro
I
[__] off working
your sweet lips sake man oh God
my friend used to massage his mom's feet
for a fiver oh
I remember
what at least
I remember this was when I was uh
probably like yeah nine or ten I had a
family friend that lived maybe like five
minutes away from me yeah I mean he used
to go to his yard quite a bit during
like summer holidays and stuff
here's pops used to make his son
um your boy or the other son uh my boy
yeah his pop so his pops used to make
his son or him rather shave his armpits
while he was laying on the sofa so he'd
lay on the soap like this on the sofa
watching TV have one
on my mother's life James on my mother's
life
um I don't know some Nigerian Channel
who knows yeah
shave me nah bro flip and do the other
one I couldn't but as a destiny yeah
yeah I couldn't believe what I was
Witnesses but you have to keep quiet
because that's that's something I've
never seen in my life bro that's
something I've never seen I'm terrified
and it's not something I've remembered
till now I couldn't yeah I can tell bro
you would have said that day one
couldn't believe it was juicy news I
couldn't believe that save me
that's the kind of stuff that I would
grow into and be thinking nah something
went on yeah
when you start looking yeah yeah this
yard wasn't wholesome wow
yeah yeah it wasn't it wasn't the one
um last but not least I had a massive
crush on my boy's twin sister it was
kind of weird because they looked alike
but I doubt one of my boys has a twin
sister um actually I have two boys who
have twin sisters
um one of them doesn't look like but
another boy who I met later in life he
has a twin sister she looks just like
him it's terrifying and to the point
where like he used to tell me about like
her boyfriends and stuff like that and I
used to want to stop him and be like no
offense bro yeah have the boyfriends met
you because I can't see her as a female
wait she's talking about your boy my boy
used to talk about his sister girlfriend
my boyfriend's okay oh my sister's
boyfriend came over with my sister the
other day and when he's talking all I
used to think about is like had they met
you bro because as soon as I saw I was
like yeah she looks just like you
that's a Butters bro I couldn't see it
if I was dating her yeah I couldn't meet
him
fast because the similarities literally
it's just hair
the difference is just the hair bro
nuts couldn't believe it mad damn it
actually made me feel like uncomfortable
how much they look to life that's that's
Peak it is Peak actually it is Peak it's
not her fault there's nobody's fault
it's no business not her fault but do
something bad it's literally though
there's doctors for this kind of stuff
oh God I'm playing anyway welcome to Joe
guys welcome guys welcome back to the
show happy Monday fun day
um as we said earlier on the episode
guys our tour starts this week we're
stopping off in Leeds on Thursday after
parties make sure you jump in
um if you are coming to show if you're
not coming sure I don't care just come
wind some yeah man grips the wall grips
um but anyway guys if you are enjoying
the show so far if you've been binging a
few episodes anything I want a bit more
and I can't be asked to be waiting every
week please head on over to patreon.com
forward slash shits and gigs where you
will find for a measly three pound a
month Tempe a day you can run the pita
SMG and you'll get years of backlog
content you will get access to our
flourishing Discord Channel where you
can build a community with the rest of
the cult babies indeed you will get
early access to our Live show tickets to
our after party tickets to anything
we've got going on you'll get preferred
opportunities over there and you get to
run around calling yourself a cult baby
for real for real the most important
most important guys if you're watching
us on YouTube please please please
subscribe to the Channel please
subscribe to the channel it means
everything to us it makes a massive
difference it does and um we want that
gold plaque we've been chatting about it
and it's not happened yet so fix it
um
and as always guys if you are listening
on any of the podcast apps uh it would
be amazing if you could leave a five
star review if that's how you feel if
that's not how you feel this time I'm
going to change the narrative keep your
opinions yourself
facts bro because I just want positivity
around me peace and positivity yeah so
if there's negative comments to be had
just say them to yourself out loud or a
friend but let's not put them on the
Internet yeah yeah let's keep them let's
keep them at the World Wide Web yeah
because there's something we're trying
to portray here and the negativity is is
dipping us uh but now I'm playing I
think I've seen like two in my entire
life so thanks for that guys but anyway
thank you for joining us and let's jump
straight into I have no idea what it's
going to be this week this week's top
five top five top five top five top five
so yeah top five top five top five this
week Ellis you should be happy you
should be okay cool privileged
the top five is games today yes let's go
let's go you don't win this a lot
there's so much pressure now yeah yeah
we can wake up at games you've got games
okay okay okay
so the top five question of this week is
can you name me the top five best
selling video games of all
[Music]
you don't have to obviously give it to
me in chronological order like five to
one but just give me the five damn all
right I'm locked in me too
yeah I'm locked in but I've got one that
I don't think I'm not sure of any of my
I'm I'm confident with with four of mine
before she's four or five oh okay let's
go run fast then I'm gonna write your
answers down as well yeah yeah let's go
all right in no particular order yeah
yeah top five selling games of all time
yeah yeah I've got Halo 3 yeah FIFA 2020
Call of Duty Black Ops 3 Pokemon
Sapphire
Halo 3 FIFA 20
um Black Ops 3 Pokemon Sapphire attack
on three
yeah yeah so no order so I've got Sonic
the first one
last of us because I know that did well
Super Mario Bros
yeah the original first one I've gone
for GTA 5 because it's literally the
biggest game everyone plays it good
shout bro I didn't even come into my
head yeah GTA if I ever lost and then
this is the gamble pong it was the first
it was the first ever game yeah it was
the first ever game
first ever video game ever created yeah
yeah
good [__] it's good so let's see let's
see
right in no particular order particular
order Super Mario Bros yeah Street
Fighter Space Invaders god of war and
Halo 3 as well so just to recap rev you
got Halo 3 FIFA 20
um Call of Duty
um Black Ops 3 Pokemon Sapphire Tekken
three Ellis you're locked here with
Sonic Number One Last of Us Super Mario
Bros GTA 5 POG Jimmy locked in with
Super Mario Bros Street Fighter space
invader God of War Halo 3.
and he said you're gonna do top 10.
it's so annoying I'm so annoyed so
number 10
was Pokemon gen one
37 million sold worldwide wow Pokemon
gen one is that Pokemon Red that would
have been or was that red yellow blue
red green one would have been red yellow
blue yeah maybe gold
don't you remember that one yeah Pokemon
red on the Game Boy that's the first one
I had that's two that's too old for you
bro yeah that would definitely be too
hard the first one I remember was
Emerald oh my God you're young
bro I stopped playing Pokemon when they
started changing different kind of
colors yeah oh really yeah Pokemon yeah
so gen one I'm assuming is because I'm
pretty sure red yellow and blue whatever
yeah with the all the exact same yeah
yeah yeah yeah and I think green as well
because it's the it's red and green yeah
the area to find an original Pokemon was
available on two version that launched
red and green before coming
um coming to other territory as Pokemon
Red and Blue and the Yellow Version came
out after when the Pikachu edition came
out yeah yeah
so when you're saying Sapphire yeah
when you said Sapphire I was I was I
thought you were gonna say Pokemon Red
and if you would have said Pokemon Red I
would have been like [__] that's
definitely in there that's number ten
that's number ten all right cool number
nine
Super Mario Bros ah why are you happy
because if we if it's I know we're not
going to do top five but if none of us
get any of the top five it's got to be
closer tonight
you've got to give yeah technically you
would give that all right all right well
you're just gonna say it's in there and
then just let me lose
all right we'll see if you any of you in
the top five all right cool number eight
OverWatch I was gonna write OverWatch
bro wow so Super Mario is a 48 mil by
the way
um OverWatch 50 mil
number seven with 50 plus mil Red Dead
Redemption two do you know what I was
gonna write when he said GTA first thing
I thought of was Red Dead yeah straight
away you don't want to make they want to
make a movie of uh they should they
should I think they're gonna do a movie
actually yeah
right that's awesome I know for a fat
Halo threes in the top five number six I
bet it's not number six we have 60.46
mil
Mario Kart 8 plus Deluxe
that doesn't surprise me though everyone
plays Mario Kart yeah
true number five I actually prefer
[Music]
75 billion my butt's tight
player unknown's Battleground oh pubg
pubg bro you think about it interesting
wow yeah interesting should have clocked
that actually
um yeah pubg was doing his team back in
the day it was number four
82.9 million
Wii sports sports
yeah that was that error [__] those kids
bro it was literally there was that
error everyone had a week wow so where
are we at on this bro we've got three
letters number three
oh God no with 175 million
only one of you got this
only one of you got this give it to me
it has to be GTA GTA 5 yes
I think everyone has ever played or
still has everyone has it yeah well
played yeah okay number two with
238 million sold
think about Minecraft wow good
oh that didn't even cross my mind bro
Jordan what's number one get it number
one with more than well more than half a
billion half a million sorry 520 million
Tetris
you see what you just see that Street
Fighter there yeah do you know what was
under that before I rubbed it out
[__] Tetris but you know why do you
know why I rubbed it out why was because
I
um was on Tick Tock the other day and I
saw a clip from a film
um about the invention of Tetris okay
and it was a guy trying to sell Tetris
to Game Boy and have it included with
the Game Boy so the reason I rubbed it
out is because you don't buy it it comes
with the Game Boy the game yeah I
[__] had Tetris in there yeah
so well done Ellis
let's go let's go four two one yeah yeah
yeah yeah four for Jimmy Two for um
Ellis is off the board let's go let's go
he's got one point we go again next one
nice God you won that thanks God a
little bit about Tetris that was a good
one
really surprised Last of Us is not even
top 10. because I know that's sold like
people it could be in top 20 to be fair
one Awards and everything surprised Halo
3 isn't bro yeah true Halo 3 was Halo 3
was the most anticipated game I've ever
heard anyone talk about ever you know
what that was that was when we were in
year 12.
if we did franchises I would have dubbed
that I didn't think about it properly
though specific games I didn't think
about it you want to do franchises think
about it that'd be cool there's no way
FIFA Halo ain't up there as franchises
for top earned no way they can make cake
yeah FIFA NBA 2K yeah uh because they're
reoccurring every like literally every
single year they're singing FIFA now
though aren't they they're changing it
now they're changing it now yeah they've
changed EA Sports I don't know they have
to change it for some reason they've
lost license yeah what used to be the
FIFA compare was it pro um Pro Evolution
Soccer Pro evil
yeah I remember that busted ass game
what's the point there's just no point
in competing bro there was no point it
was dead um but yeah that was top five
top five top five guys let us know if
you got any of the answers in the
comments below right guys let's take a
quick break to spread awareness about
male grooming okay summer's coming guys
are you ready to unveil your Beach board
question mark question mark question
mark manscaped is here to ensure your
body is ready for the wild with their
game changing full body grooming and
hygiene products facts don't be the guy
at the beach with Austin Powers chest
hair and if you grew some winter man
tits the least you can do is make sure
their hairless blood clots that's a
groovy baby bro it's time to get ready
for your hot guy Summer by going to
madscape.com and for 20 off plus free
shipping you just need to use the code
sng you already know Sierra November
Golf and guys let's get back to the
episode thank you very much right moving
on
marry the First Sight I'm gonna be
concise REM let's do this baby
I wish REM had a camera just then top
five just finished he was like this
scratch yeah
I watched four episodes yesterday so
guys I'm like still like six or seven
behind but bear with me there's juicer
foot there's juice a foot and I've got
some speculations as well okay let's go
right so I can't remember where we left
off the last one either tonight but I'll
I'll run it up right I think last time I
spoke about maybe Harrison throwing down
under the bus
Yes actually and then man apologizing
blah blah he got him gifts yeah yeah I
think so oh and last time I spoke about
Okay Google last time I spoke about
Claire coming clean yes
boring old news
no one gives a damn anymore right yeah
right I'm actually I'll tell you what
I'm gonna let REM pick the couples and I
will say where I'm at with them okay
wait have you got up to the retreat here
I've just finished the retreat okay
yeah let's go yeah
all right cool talk to me about Duncan
and Alyssa family
okay fam okay the power couple of the
whole show is what always happens it
happened last season as well okay so
last season there was one Don I can't
remember his name lovely lovely lovely
guy loves his mom loves his sister takes
care of everyone he got the cutest most
boring quaintest little thing and they
were the most boring couple throughout
the whole show as soon as you said that
yeah first time you started talking
about Maps I think you said yeah as soon
as you got into family week
she Twisted it and she actually just
before family she Twisted it and she was
a [__] bro it's a hammer in general to
all the other girls at first she would
gun for arguments at first gone for
arguments and her man just couldn't
understand the beef of it bro
um she went to that screen time boy she
factually did the producer bought it
inside and said you're boring yeah how
do you suck your ratings are Rock Bottom
do something cook something that's all
she did and then
when obviously this last season when you
got to like family week they'd be
staying with him she'd be staying with
him and all this stuff and she'd be like
big man stop going Jim is so boring
you're wasting everyone's time stop and
he was like raw blood this is my thing
yeah allow me she's like [__] boring
you're boring everything's boring bro
whatever do you love me or not yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah crazy okay anyway yeah
Alyssa is the new thing Alyssa and
Duncan Duncan loves her so this has got
a u right Duncan loves her bro and like
he's like I'm on it like whatever
whatever you've got whatever baggage
you've got give it all to me okay um on
it bro I came here if I love and I came
to get married okay we love each other
we clap cheeks every night were you on
so they went to this Couple's Retreat
they all go to the house and all the
couples have to live together for like a
week right
out of nowhere
dunkers would demand them one day yeah
he's just would demand them one day
playing tennis playing tennis he goes
into the bedroom just like ah what a fun
[__] day yeah she's doing her makeup
yeah and she's just like mm-hmm
says oh it goes to give her a kiss on
Jimmy walk on baby this is going on she
said do you know I exist big man he said
what she was like where the [__] have
you been all day this is a boy it's
holiday to you I'm here alone I need
attention Duncan give me attention give
me attention he said whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
I've been busy with demanding I didn't
know you why why didn't you come and say
something to me she was I didn't know
where you were
he was like well could you not find me
yeah could you not come up to me could
you not look for me and he's like big
man you're out here playing tennis why
should I find you he's like so you
didn't know where I was fat
she she spotted all of it and so anyway
she beefed and beefed and beefed him and
he's like right I'm so sorry he took
family took all the accountability he
said I'm so sorry I didn't know that's
how you felt I'm sorry that's how you
feel but I'm here for you so let's kiss
let's make up whatever I can do to make
it better I will do yeah fam
she went and run off to the girls and
was like
[__] Duncan bro she might also goes and
[__] donkey start crying they're like
what's wrong what's wrong she said
this motherfucker's been airing me all
day when I brought her up to him he said
I'm sorry you feel that way
popped and screwed the whole thing it's
like crying their eyes out and all the
girls were like [__] this guy ah man
these men seem to forget like we are
watching you lamb well what you like she
spun the whole thing I couldn't believe
what I was watching I mean Duncan's DM's
right there he's she's lying bro she's
lying read this the bags bro
I need to know he's here for real and he
doesn't give me any affirmations bro but
all he does is give affirmations that's
all he does
and these were the boys like bro I'm
here for I tell her every day I'm here
for him I'm here for you I'm here for
this I'm here for that bro and I told
you boy he's handsome as [__] Duncan bro
they're all talking Taylor's talking
about how her man is not her type she
randomly jumps in it was like Duncan
ain't my type for [__] all the girls are
pardon excuse me your man's banging bro
what do you mean he's not your type
season [__] him he's not my type
[__] him he's not my type
he's a hater and he's not my type bro
[__] I need affirmations that I need a
man wow it was crazy bro she's been
spinning for time and the episode I'm on
now that I had to pause because I had to
go to sleep yeah yeah
um is the dinner party okay and I know
that I know at the ceremony it's all
going to get revealed because
she's gonna keep running her mouth and
he's gonna tell his truth and the girls
are all going to hear that she's like I
know that's what's going to happen it
has to happen they need to leave the
experiments she's a crazy person
it's nuts give me the next couple I
um let's go I hate these two
Bronte Harrison my God I thought we're
saving this for last week jumping
straight in from
a party and Harrison bro
yeah yeah I've listened so I've told you
Harrison is a narcissist yes a
manipulator yes a gas lighter he's
everything bad about the world bro yeah
and he loves it he thinks he's man dog
bro he's sits and then Giggles to
himself he thinks he's got the whole
thing on a puppet thing he thinks he's
puppeteering the whole charade bro
everyone's on to him and he thinks he's
smarter than everyone's okay sociopath
okay bro so basically
obviously they used to have that beef
Harrison's the one that draws the girl's
number yeah deleted it yeah
um lies lies lies so last few weeks he's
been coming out and just been like bro
me and Bronte we're here one day Bronte
just like clicked her brain off and was
like I can't be asked to beef him
anymore so whatever we're doing we're
doing together okay
crazy but admirable she said I I walked
down the aisle with this man I'm right
I'm coming
right or die okay she's willing to lose
every brethren in this house to be with
him and she sees what he's on and you
can tell she's like [__] my life yeah
he's like she's like I'm with you yeah
if you're with me I'm [__] with you
Bonnie and Clyde yeah you're with me or
not yeah is he with me or yeah bam
that's it yeah so Harrison has been
moving brazy and then um so anyway
they're power couple now or they're
moving like their power couple now they
get to the retreat and basically all the
girls pull Bronte the side and said your
man's cracked bro okay he's manipulating
you he's gaslighting you you need to
lock him off
she was like stop stop stop is fine and
then Melinda Melinda has got a [__]
mouth on her yeah okay and she is one of
those people I know she means well yeah
she's one of these people that thinks
she can say what she wants because it's
the truth with no consequences and if I
beef you about what you're saying to me
it's because I can't handle the truth
okay that's the kind of person she is
okay she'll say what the [__] she wants
yeah and then when you're like what did
you say to me or is it her truth it's
technically the truth that's her truth
it mixes matches okay sometimes it's the
truth sometimes it's her truth okay but
she needs to mince her words okay she
needs to speak to people correctly yeah
so everyone's on a very very lovey-dovey
Bronte we're here for you we are here
for you you need to understand your
man's not good Melinda jumps in and says
bro the whole thing's toxic and you're
[__] naive Bronte said pardon excuse
me she said your naive brother
she says say less bro I don't need to
[__] hear another word of your mouth
naive she said so I'm naive so I don't I
can't think for myself I'm dumb you're
saying I'm dumb bro and she was like big
man
wear it
yeah and as she's walked off Melinda's
like bro she's [__] naive what do you
want me to say so the next day bronte's
like
run me an apology now for calling me
naive Melinda playing victim she was
like big man everyone at the table is
going naive or everyone else is thinking
it I just said it it's just one of them
[__] bro she said everyone else is
thinking that bro I'm just saying it she
said swear I apologize now bro
so Melinda she said I'm sorry about the
naive thing but it came from a place of
love I hope you understand where I'm
coming from they squashed it
Harrison yeah he wants everyone to break
up okay okay listen Harrison he picks
his targets and he needs to have them
break up yeah but for no reason
no one can understand so Melinda and
Bronte they've squashed it they're boys
again now yes they tried to cook
Harrison he got away with it it's fine
loud it
then we had a boys night and a girls
night so once they've squashed this beef
Melinda and Evelyn got a bit tipsy and
were like let's sneak over to the boys
night and see what they were separate
agendas yeah to see how they're
confiding in one another okay bro
so sneak over to the boys and Harrison
is Grid in Leighton which is Melinda's
man and said bro
okay I don't think you man are he said
what's going on with you Melinda he said
bro Harrison's asking lay in this
Harrison said to Leighton welcome for
you and Melinda how you how you man
doing he said bro I really like people
get along great but sometimes we we butt
heads sometimes it's up and down but
we're fantastic Harrison said bro I'm
not gonna lie to you Melinda's toxic
brov and like your whole relationship is
a facade you're among men you need to
tell the truth your relationship with
Joe Leyton it's got a [__] on him
he's a CEO with a [__] on it and he said
who the [__] are you talking to yeah
okay don't chat about my relationship so
let's go don't what do you mean facade
roll how is it facade when I just told
you was up and down I'm giving you
truths and you're chatting me about
toxic don't even try it I appreciate you
trying to weigh in but shut your [__]
mouth and chat to me I was zipped it but
I told you Melinda and Evelyn had snuck
in to listen they didn't hear late and
say that all they heard was Harrison say
this toxic is this is that oh okay I
mean it was like I can't hear another
word of this so they storied back off
they've got Snippets ran back off and
the Melinda with our Hot Head
ran back over to Bronte and was like
coincidence I just listened to your man
gun in my relationship what the [__] do
you have to say about it
and then Bronte was like
did we not just squash this are we
joining the hit big man chat to me like
let's see what I do to you bro
she stood up immediately yeah yeah I
said two nights in the road with his
[__] yeah yeah versus a two-ness in a
room with his [__] bro
I speak for myself facts facts facts
facts I swear down bro
so anyway
bro it was it was heated yeah yeah yeah
and she's in there just brawl out what
did I say bro don't chat to me about
this kind of stuff so she's she's she's
back in her room Shadow Boxing yeah yeah
like oh I can't take it anymore
um Harrison rocks up loud babe
she's been up balling I can't take it
anymore why is she speaking to me like
this so Harrison Russell Bay what go on
so
she says bro
[__] Melinda and uh Evelyn snuck up
on you man listening and I said what he
said they're listening to you man and
she heard you cussing them out yeah
um and now she's rocked up to me and
said how do you feel about it you're my
saying this how do you like we're join
at the hip or some [__]
Harrison said say less Leighton told me
that they're not good and there's no
future
lied bro chat when everyone knows
letting gondin bro he said late don't
worry about Melinda and Leighton bro
Leighton just told me that they're
they're basically done but there's no
future when man just said it's up and
down he said it's a bit up and down
I'm open and honest yeah wow he said
Leighton said this talked bro so Bronte
said say less say for that ammo so when
they went to Bronte the next day called
Melinda almost like let's have a chat
yeah I'm not gonna have you chat to me
about naive I'm not gonna have you chat
to me like I don't speak for myself I'm
not gonna have it bro I walked down the
aisle of Harrison he's my man
don't throw stones at glass houses
[Music]
Frozen glass houses what the [__] you
talking about and she said I think you
know what I'm talking about
Amanda said I don't think I do and she
said maybe you need to attach to your
husband if you don't know what I'm
talking about and she said walk what
said your husband's running around
telling all the boys that's talked bro
and you're talking about my man's a
manipulator your man's running his mouth
she said my hubby would never say that
she walked up so late and leighton's not
on smoke at all she wrapped up to Layton
and said look
Iverson's running bars did you say or
not Leighton said [__] no I didn't say
that [__] no I didn't say that yeah she
said then let's run up on them right now
let's militant she said run up on him
right now
[__] that it doesn't matter what he's
saying I'm telling you I didn't say it
she said now you need to be a man run up
on him bro she said she turned she broke
the floor full turn to the camera and
said someone speak to this man I'm not
talking in English
speak to him bro oh wow it's really real
she stood up and you know when it's not
produced
to this [__] yeah he ain't doing [__]
[__] Elena said they have a little
dinner party later a couple drinks told
you Lane's got a [__] on him yeah yeah
yeah yeah he takes his girl by the by
the ways I said let's squash some stuff
yeah in front of everyone in front in
front of he pulled Bronte and Harrison
to the side okay so let's squash him
[__] on a real peaceful thing and when
he's talking he loves to stroke his
girls back yeah yeah see how the tight
dress on he stays joking obey he can't
help it he's literally
yeah yeah
so he pulled up
I said Bronte what did you tell my wife
that apparently I said so she as a
Bronte
none more wiser was like yeah yeah
Harrison told me that blah blah blah
blah blah blah Elaine says swear
Harrison swear
Harrison said bro family time to Bronte
said no offense I don't know what you're
talking about
the bus he picked on a Dasher under the
bus he said Brunswick to be fair I don't
want to [__] your Saiyan
it was wild that was wild and she's so
puppeted yeah I must have heard it wrong
no yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah Harrison I'm
sorry and he said it's calm yeah he said
you [__] he whisper says you [__] up
yeah he said I wish you never said that
[__] we're in this
Harrison yeah I said I'm sorry I heard
the wrong thing
master manipulator manipulator crazy wow
he's a modern day pimp bro wow he's a
modern day pimp it's emotional
manipulation
crazy she said well I'm so she said babe
I'm sorry I must I've caused this whole
drama he said babe it's fine you [__]
it but it's fine but he said it you
[__] it
saying that's a Bronte family and it was
like you shouldn't have done that yeah
you should not have done that but it's
calm and handle it your man's gonna
handle it she said babe I'm thank you
I'm sorry
it was crazy bro so lady said watch your
[__] mouth and then uh Harrison was
like bro I didn't say that my wife's
chatting [__] it's crazy squash now
it's squash now
Melinda came for blood though yeah yeah
yeah yeah she was like [__] this you are
this you are that huh hers the word for
word he covered his wife's is and said
Melinda just says stuff sometimes don't
listen to him and his wife is a child
she just says stuff let's chat she just
says stuff fan she was like your
relationship is fake bro your
relationship is fake Bronte Turtle
around to everyone who else thinks my
relation is fake fam couple people was
yep not gonna lie I said it's a bit fake
because no one didn't want to speak up
yeah but unless I pointed people out
Harrison was like Claire do you think
it's fake or not Claire was like fine
I'm not gonna like yeah a little bit
don't call my name is Gonna Hear My
Truth yeah yeah don't call my name bro
she said a little bit bro and then as
soon as Claire said a little bit
everyone was like
Harrison says swear you might think is
fake say less anyone anyway they all
went home they all [__] off home yeah
took bronte's hand over her home cut to
scene next scene florentine's crying
said Harrison broke up with me
bro is a matting broke up me of a text
what are they in the same family they're
in the same thing but he must have
dipped out because he must have said to
her these men are saying we're fake he's
crazy bro these men are saying were fake
I need to know your inner in it she said
big man I'm in it she said I want your
kids I want to move to your city I'm
willing to do everything he said your
[__] bro he said I'm not feeling it
Francine they're saying we're fake prove
them wrong bro I'm here for you Bronte
prove them wrong bro she said give me
you now good morning
while he's a manipulator yeah and he
said and then she she got so stressed
out she was like I want to go home yeah
I can't handle this he said bro you
actually want to go home you want to
abandon me again again we're done we're
done bro fam that's what he does he
pushes her to the edge to the point
where she was like I'd rather die than
be in this conversation anymore and he's
like wow that's how I know you know
really real yeah I'm here for everything
he uses that yeah push it to the point
where she can't take it yeah as soon as
she says I have to leave he's like here
we go again running away from me again
Bronte I'm here we're breaking the [__]
up Jesus Christ she she was distraught
so that's where I'm at with the episode
I pause the episode there yeah went to
sleep yeah okay cool
next couple next couple
um
wow Tyler Hugo
Taylor and Hugo yeah
so in order to address this I'm gonna
we're gonna have to skip
I'm glad you said that because we have
to go all the way back way back way back
yeah because the last time you spoke
about them and you were saying how Peak
it was with their living conditions when
they first moved in
you missed out okay when you talk about
where Hugo can sleep which he was saying
oh yeah you can sleep there I thought
you were gonna elaborate and say
um the Wardrobe that she was allowing
him to have actually was the electrical
cupboard yeah she said you put your gobs
in the electrical cover yeah
um
but right I'm gonna have to wheel it all
the way back so keep up with me I'm
listening
it all starts with Rupert
yeah Evelyn's man yes
right I'm gonna put my foot down right
now and say it
this guy is Ops okay he Baroque bro code
in half right snapped it he snapped it
and he's he's feeding everyone a lie
okay on a Harrison table or Worse fam
not worse he's just a [__] yeah you'll
find out okay so all the Monday and went
on a night out right yeah yeah yeah this
is what happened all the man that won a
night out everyone's get get get get
yeah yeah so oh man everyone Night Out
everyone's drunk
apparently Rupert butt dialed while
they're in a club Rupert thousand
twenties on an iPhone with facial
recognition come on bro butt dialed
Evelyn only Evelyn like three or four
times
during this butt dial Evelyn overheard
two husbands chatting [__] about their
wives
firstly
imma come back to Rupert Taylor um
Dan was slagging off his wife Sandy okay
so a little bit of a jump from where I
left Donna Sandy
on their last commitment ceremony
they will call Lady da but she's like
I'm not getting anything physical from
him it's Dan and Sandy okay
I'm not getting nothing physical from
him okay Dan said she's cool but I don't
find her physically attractive bro okay
Sandy's not the one that just wanted to
bang all the time that's Melissa that
wasn't Melissa yeah yeah it's getting
there yeah that's what made Josh cry
yeah
um cool so sand is the Indian thing she
left the whole culture place
so when I did this at the ceremony yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so he said I'm just
not physically attracted to her right
now but we're building something right
now yeah fam the next morning he banged
her so they must have had an argument
yeah yeah you know I would yeah yeah
yeah yeah they had an argument and they
must have been on a face-to-face yeah
then he said the argument went from beef
to lips into banging
after that day he wouldn't look at her
he was sleeping on the sofa he was bro
he was doing all sorts so
basically he's doing all this and then
um he's basically trying to say he's
doing up me time for like six hours a
day and every time he comes home she's
like oh where you been he's not been at
the gym don't ask me questions she's
like six hours he's like I like my me
time
so she's like cool bro so anyway they're
doing their thing they're doing saying
he's like I'm literally looking for
someone with who's a bit more like has
my lifestyle I've been more active yeah
he said I want someone who's all more
active like ah we're so different and
she's like it doesn't matter if we're
different your me time is your me time
yeah yeah if you want to run gym beach I
don't need to be there do that and if I
want to read books and watch Bollywood
movies I'm gonna do that facts and then
we can spend time together outside of
that and he was like you're not getting
it bro so he was trying [__] yeah he
just wants me and he was just like
enough
because he was like you're not making
sense she was like I'm making perfect
sense yeah um and she had no one there
to back her up
so anyway that will happen that happened
um he banned it once hasn't banged her
again she's getting upset and Brock's
Peak and then basically all the boys
went out this butt dial happened and
Evelyn overheard him okay [__] about her
okay and thank you for the throwback
content yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm here now
fam he's on his phone showing pictures
of his exes saying look how banging this
guy is to the boys bro command him this
is my ex I got bang and she is this is
my other it's like a bang as she is
Sandy's just not myself I don't like
Asians bro just saying just say you
don't like eggs what are we doing be a
man facts facts bro so anyway he's
slagging her off Sagar off Evelyn's like
raw
and then uh Hugo who's been like his
wife Taylor has been treating him like
[__] absolute [__] from day one bro even
because there's a they're not on this
thing yeah yeah yeah so there was even
like a photo challenge yeah where you
rank your partner in comparison to all
the other ones right you saying so when
they did it yeah he got he had enough
bro so he got her picture and said let
me ask you a question yeah based on how
you've treated me since the day we met
where would you place yourself in this
list we're talking about now Hugo said
that to Taylor okay where would you
place yourself in this Penance list
based on how you treated me where do you
think I should put you she put herself
last
she was like based on how treated you I
put myself right here lost
and he said I'll can't let you do that
I'll put you second to last
it was Big Dick Energy he'd had enough
bro he'd had enough of her anyway so
when he was with the mandem had a few
drinks he was like I hate this [__] I
wish I had any other wife she doesn't
give me any respect
he doesn't let me sleep in the same bed
she doesn't let me talk to her she won't
touch let me touch her
I can't stand her is this the one that
says sleeping Arrangements he said first
now I'm gonna take the bed and he's like
no the whole thing yeah she said I'm
taking a whole thing sleep on a
windowsill um I said it's cold over
there yeah he just freezing cold it's
nuts so anyway wow that's what happened
so now dance
um [__] yeah because evident overheard
um him trying to [__] yep and now uh
Hugo's [__] because uh Evelyn
overheard him talk [__] so she's
Evelyn's ran over to um so she's run off
to Sandy and Below bro I ever heard Dan
saying this that and the other Santa
said say let's [__] this guy
um beefed him about it they went to the
commitment ceremony and she was like
[__] him he's a waste Man Dan was like
Fez they both left okay yeah they both
left he was going to leave anyway he was
leaving bro he was chatting the most to
get out of it fun he was chatting he
kept saying the ocean's calling me bro
he was like I need I've got a love of
the ocean she has eczema she can't touch
the ocean he said this [__] is allergic
to water I need the ocean and the
experts were like big man
um
so so obviously Hugo was chatting [__]
yes he took full accountability yes and
was like I'm sorry I was saying this
stuff but like
I was saying it because I was hurt I was
down bad bro she's been cheating me like
[__] and Taylor was like I haven't
treated you like anything and every time
he would say one word she would jump in
and be like shut up bro you're trying to
[__] you're a liar I can't be spoken to
you she literally says shut your mouth
you don't get to speak that's what she
said shut up you don't get to speak
everyone had to jump in like I would
look at the producers get me off the
show because I'm gonna do science yeah
get me off this [__] shot
so she was like yeah yeah shut up shut
up shut up shut up you're a [__] you
just [__] about me
but anyway so as that's happening he's
trying to experience of the experts like
bro I'm sorry I did this and they're
like you can't chat about your wife like
that I don't care if you're unloading
stuff with your boys you can't because
you called her a [__] so you can't call
your wife stuff like that and he was
like I'm sorry I didn't know about the
butt dial
so Rupert was like why are you saying
butt dial like that and then Harrison
was like you know damn way away right
now bro facts Rupa got nervous bro and
he's like left right left right yeah
yeah looking for help someone helped me
he was like there was a butt dial and
everyone's like yeah there was a butt
dial don't you dare accuse my husband to
be a liar you're calling me a liar
Harris is a damn [__] strength on
your life yeah how's it going to be a
butt dial yeah and I wish I was in that
room because I'd have been a Rupert bro
yeah I like you cause but you're a
little snitch right bro what's going on
this is Bro Code star facts you run to
your misses and told her and then was
definitely 100 what's happened
because he's heard all this stuff he's
skipped back to his paying ass misses
and said I've got some tea for you and
she was like tell me immediately and he
said whatever you say does not leave
this room bro but Dan was doing up this
because Evelyn's saying she knows Dan
was showing pictures of his ex how would
you know that on a butt dial yeah yeah
it's impossible bro yeah so anyway he's
run home he's definitely told Evelyn
I've got some tea I need to spill it and
she would admit she would have said run
me everything you have and um
he would have been like babe Dan was
doing this and Hugo was doing all of
this and she would have been like first
of all I'm telling Sandy today
I literally said he can't leave the room
but she's my girl yeah she's my bridge
and I'm not gonna hear this I'm not
saying anything he's a racist
I'm not just gonna sit here with a
racist
while he's living with my girl I'm not
gonna do it and he would have been like
all right well you need you're not
throwing me what the facts not again
you're not you're not throwing me under
here bro so we need to come with a plan
yeah say let's just say you butt dialed
me yeah yeah so you butt dialed me three
or four times and I heard the whole
thing I'll I'll cover you I'll cover you
and you're like babe please you have to
tell the truth yeah yeah so anyway
that's what's happened so people think
um people think Rupert's Ops a few man
thinking up
when they really need to because
everyone knows he's trying to [__] yeah
everyone knows the battle doesn't happen
but no one in apart from Harrison I
don't rate Harrison but no one else in
the group of men is willing to say like
hey man
it's bros before hoes bro and yeah you
don't run to your wife and say what's
going on you can confront brother yeah
in the group of men if my name is saying
all this [__] about his wife you can
confront him and been like big man what
your doings out of order and if you're
not gonna go home and squashes your wife
I promise you I'll go tell her because
you're being a piece of [__] but what
you do not do is run to your wife spill
everything spill everything that
everyone's saying sit back yeah because
he's
he could have said bear [__]
but he's the same way everyone else said
he's been a little [__] I don't write
Rupert for that there's rules to the
game bro and even though these men are
moving like [__] it wasn't his job
to run back to his misses and say what I
said and then say it was a butt dial
[__] Bro there's no such thing one of
you might can never run out to me
there's no such thing as buttons one of
your man can never run that to me but
now I say butt down right now right now
I lie do it right do it right now yeah
Harrison said he tried four times
houses are funny because me and Bronte
tried to butt dial thing four times
yesterday didn't work didn't work
literally didn't work it's impossible
yeah Rupert's a waste man for that
anyway so Dan and Sandy are gone yep
fam Hugo was like I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry Taylor was like literally
whatever so she was like I'm leaving by
the way he wrote stay so they had to
stay for one more week yeah so they had
to go to the retreat together
she didn't look at him in this retreat
but she was gripped in cam
she likes us some cam which doesn't make
any sense by the way no it doesn't yeah
Cameron uh yeah she likes herself some
Cameron yeah okay this is a little
country bumpkin and she's a little
country thing as well okay so she likes
herself a country done okay she's been
up on him
and he's feeling her a little bit
because when she was upset he pulled it
aside and said give me a hug come on
come on come on give me a hug it didn't
make sense he pulled her to the side
wait she was upset and he pulled her yep
that makes it literally made no sense
fine none it was back out
Lindell Lindell the one with assisted
five
um
yeah so
so um so anyway so yeah he's been
gripped to Taylor but it's come to
um Hugo said what he said he's upset oh
my God I forgot to say and when they're
at the retreat Taylor's done with him by
the way okay but she hasn't told him
she's been lying to him to keep the
peace to Hugo to Hugo okay Google I
forgive her forgive him he's like really
and she's like yeah even though she
knows she's going oh she does for a fact
yeah she'll literally run straight to
the camera oh [__] him like
it's taught no way so she'll go so
she'll chat to him and then she got a
couple of Tipsy one night so I'd run to
the to the to the gal and was like bear
in mind she doesn't want to be touched
by him and when from day one she's like
don't touch me
I take a long time to warm up and I'm
not a very physical person
I just don't want to be touched if you
can respect that he was like of course I
can respect that some people don't have
to be touched if I'm actually had a
couple Wines in her she thought she was
alone with the girls she was like me and
my ex he will bang me every day and need
it every day I need it every day and
she's like raw so why did you break up
and she was like break up he texted me
this morning
said we should do some phone sexting
no and I'm horny bro
Hugo was sat two benches away yeah she
she didn't think that she was just
talking to the girls from she knew where
Hugo was where he was saying I don't
care bro he's just over there a couple
meters whatever just there she didn't
care how he was upset [__] [__] how
are we letting this run bro so he tried
to pull her up later on in the week and
was like later on in the week fam yeah
in fact he's scared of her if you had
he's terrified of her
he's terrified of her bro
um so anyway at the last night he was
like before we wrap this whole thing up
in front of everyone who's like I need
to understand why I'm going for this
exiting she was like texting she was
like yeah with the sexting and all this
sexting what are you accusing me of
playing he tried to say one more word
she says shut up you're doing it again
in front of everyone in front of
everyone shut up I'm walking off this oh
facts I'm walking off the show so this
is my reputation yeah next day was the
dinner party he was like getting dressed
they slept separately he was getting
dressed and he was like I just hope we
can squash it like I hope we can go
there tonight the camera to camera I
hope we can squash it I'm gonna meet her
there tonight offer a drink and I just
hope it's calm bro because I don't want
to fight anymore I want my wife I don't
want to fight anymore I want peace and I
want love and I want my wife
fun
she did she's not on the show she texts
Claire like Claire nice to meet you I'm
back at yard
[__] this experiment of [__] you go my
[__] she didn't go to the dinner she
didn't tell him he was going he's man he
skipped in there like complimenting
everyone like you look pain Bang Gang a
and there was like oh where's uh Taylor
they knew where she was the worst Taylor
I was like oh we stepped separately
obviously you saw a bit of beef we
stepped separately but I'm waiting for
it to come so we can like squash it up
and then um yeah bro
she's dipped so Claire was like let me
have a word farm so yeah clap onto the
side and was like Fam I'm not gonna lie
to you your wife dipped your wife dipped
ages ago
that
there must be some sort of like wave
ideas man signed like any emotional
damage you man retrieve on this show
that's not my business yeah you know
what I mean because that's emotional
damage
so that's that's what I've literally
paused the show right there so right now
the the the source is Harrison broke up
with Bronte and he still rocked up to
the dinner party yeah because he said
we're married he said we're boys but
we're still married so I'm gonna do my
part and um Hugo's just found out his
wife did that's what's happening right
now end scene we'll figure out while
going next week damn okay I'm I'm
interested as every time you do a recap
it gets juicier and juicier and juicier
it's good it's good because it's
obviously because you're watching in
bulkers yeah yeah yeah yeah it's good
it's good it's good as good as good as
yes
um say less right
so you had a question for me I do have a
question for you and I saw this question
I Believe on
Instagram maybe or Twitter so I don't
want to get like the props for it but
I'm gonna ask you the question anyway it
was a video and it said would you rather
fight a chicken every time you got into
your car
or fight a lion once every year chicken
you get in your car
more multiple times a day every day yeah
yeah it'll be the worst thing ever
um but it will increase my health
because I'll just start walking places
like how bad do I need this car bro
so I'll drive less yeah a lion yeah I
won't make it past the first fight
a lion once a year though once a year
once done
it will kill me bro what are we talking
about I'm dead did you have to fight to
the death you just have to square up it
will kill me in one swipe unless you
dodge it
you fighting chickens every day three
four times a day I'd hate it I would
hate it but I know I'm winning 10 times
out of 10. I'm coming up with Battle
Scars
but a lion will kill me
Allah will kill me so easily about Dodge
it yeah that's not a fight is it it's
not a swing once I dodge and I'm like
yeah that's my fight for the year yeah
no no say do something
yeah yeah in fact because I wouldn't the
thing with the chicken right it it will
probably surprise me every single time I
open the car door oh because there'll be
times I'm in a rush and I think yeah
yeah I'm in a rush I'm late for cyan and
I open the door and there's just a
chicken going crazy bro just going crazy
jumping up about in all different
seasons
I'll punch it in his chest every day
squaring his chest bro
I'll snap his Wishbone
I I can't because I'm not gonna try and
grab it I can't deal with stuff like
that wait you leave the carcass in the
car oh facts bro
as soon as it's flapping I would just be
like ah and as soon as I can see my shot
yeah whack I just left and it'll sit
down like oh God
if I just leave it you start driving it
starts twitching oh no no no it comes
back to life no bro oh my god oh [__]
I couldn't find a chicken yeah I
couldn't find chicken that would I'm
just gonna start walking bro walking and
busting Ellis did you busting you know
you could have catch me and let's see
what would you do
be the chicken as well mum you fight a
chicken they can scrap that I used to
have chickens they can scrap I know they
cry yeah they don't know they don't look
like but um they're just on stuff yeah
it's not like James said it you're not
making it past the a line
that's not happening so yeah chicken Red
Chicken Chicken yeah I'm not fighting a
lion bro you're not surviving that yeah
no one surviving no one surviving that
so I thought of because you might get
well I know you get your car multiple
times a day every day so telling you bro
and then like you said I will forget
most days [__] especially when I'm
rushing around I'll jump in and just the
flaps
every day and then once sometimes you go
in your car not even to drive off
because you're looking for something oh
imagine you're just open even you open
the boot where my airpods bro and it's
just chickens oh because you're not
opening an age to [__] everywhere yeah
and the thing is sometimes it will get
good to me and I'll rock it in like two
seconds yeah and I'm like [__] yeah and
then I'll get in the next day
oh and it's just drama I'm missing
punches yeah it's Peter Griffin
I'll be livid
let's do tweets of the week imma kick it
off
um let me give you the imagery first
right before I say the the Tweet so
there's a guy tapping a girl on the
shoulder and they're both naked okay
you tried your best but it was too much
teeth the Uber's outside
draw fam I feel some teeth in my day how
about you I felt some teeth in my day
wow I found this one sweet at me if it's
throbbing inside of you move
if it's throbbing inside of you move bro
I'm not in there
move bro emergency stations
I'm not moving yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
you don't gotta put your phone on do not
disturb around me baby I know you're a
rental
oh
rental I know you've got a girl at home
I know you're a rental
wow go say horrible outlandish factual
stuff factual stuff I know I could be
confronted for stuff like that I know
your rental
because you'd want to keep the light
going yeah
what are you sure about
that's crazy fan sweet of me I love
myself but I'm still getting a BBL
I love us I'm still getting a BBM Oh my
days I want cheeks bro oh my God yeah
that's all there was in L.A oh facts
that's all there was in L.A videos
everywhere
all right I'm a straight man but when I
touch drugs I turn by and some of our
boys look tasty
[Laughter]
ah
raw some of my boys look tasty
that's crazy bro that's actually mad
Jesus and this was me from ages 6 to
like 13.
this is it you ever just be chilling a
ram did you check randomly check if you
have super powers
bro you didn't bro you didn't who Dragon
Ball Z that was in the mirror all the
time I'm sure I used to feel the
pressure man yeah yeah and I'll be there
because I would why I would do is I get
my sister to push and I'd pull like this
so you know where you get that bounce
team yeah I'll do like this and then go
bro
you know that bro I used to think I had
telekinesis sometimes sometimes I'll
just be staring at a glass of water and
just fly
foreign
facts come to me bro yeah all right
do you be trying to bend you all crazy
during sex like calm down before I fart
who be fat if I was a ting
I'll be popping non-stop right you can't
grab my ankles and go like this yeah
that's too much greedy yeah that's too
much Freedom you can't be backshotting
me and saying open the cheeks of course
I'm popping bro
[Applause]
those are a different breed they are
they literally are flowers
for what we put them through flowers at
once
bro
ones yeah yeah wow legs behind heads
facts bro and they're just firm
everything they're just fine oh congrats
yeah literally
No Cap I used
No Cap I used to eat the Barbie dolls
coochie when I was younger
that's disgusting bam this tiny little
thing
No Cap No Cap bro I used to eat my
Barbie dolls Gucci when I was younger
that's wild that's
oh that's wild God that is wild
fingers were inside me last night but
they don't work to text me back today
the absolute cheek
the absolutely God I'm telling you the
girls go through it bro they really do
oh that's funny a fam
this is how we know girls love
horror stuff okay him
she's always on her phone I wonder who
she's talking to me Google's did Jeffrey
Dahmer use seasonings
oh God all right
they were really calling ugly girls
grenades on Jersey Shore that Lincoln
was sick as hell
bro
grenade do you remember Jersey Shore
this was like Circle what 2010 2009 2010
2011. yeah what a reality TV yeah it was
crazy bro if you weren't watching Jersey
Shore you weren't on stuff
Farm grenades grenades Paulie dibro fats
grenade whistle yeah yeah it's the
grenade whistle that's so Peak so
such a good show fam this one's random
fam the baby mamas is the baby mamas is
outside I repeat El Bebe Madres esta
afuera
hahaha
foreign
time I was on a date in high school and
I got pulled over by a police oh sorry I
got pulled over and the police officer
let me off with a warning but find my
date a hundred dollars because she was
only five for eight and by law she was
supposed to be in the booster seat and I
honestly think about this a lot five for
eight is booster four eight sorry did I
say five yeah yeah four foot eight four
foot eight four for eight she needs to
be in a booster seat she got fined
that's your girl
[Music]
because I'm not dealing with fines every
day and I'm not watching my girl in a
booster seat I'm not a nonce my guy
I want an adult relationship I'm sorry
you're that short it's not your fault
it's not your fault yeah yeah I'm not on
it wow fam
this one's funny
bro my car just got declined while uh
while buying a homeless person a
McChicken and he laughed at me this guy
said sit out here with me somebody's
gonna come through for us oh my God that
is that is a different type of
embarrassment I'll choke him I wouldn't
be I wouldn't want to touch a bad one
yeah I wouldn't want to touch it
oh [__] he will inject Me With Science
wow wow
why we can't afford to make chicken come
here with me now you're silly because
you should have known your card your
bank balance was slim you need to know
what's going on you need to know what
the transactions are saying before
you're doing up bloody darling Oh my
days that's it that's one thing one
resolution I'm moving forward for the
rest of the year I need to check my bank
balance every day I I never check it
I don't check mine as often but I've
told you recently I've been
um I've got the uh the notification so
every time my money goes in or money
comes out it pops up on the phone so I
know yeah yeah and I should be checking
I need to check my balance every day
when I was on holiday Jay said something
that was
profound man said I'm out here checking
Instagram every day and I don't even
know how much money is in my account I
was like ah facts I go sometimes over a
week if I check in my account sometimes
two facts bro I don't yeah yeah I don't
know what's in there and sometimes I say
sometimes these days most of the time
I'm shocked when I open it yeah
so stuff's been coming out
I don't know what's going on yeah yeah
yeah yeah it needs to be on top of it
every day I need to know how much is in
there so this is my last one fam
I'm a 90s kid no you're a 30 year old
man
or roll
I'm a 90s baby you're a 30 year old man
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
plot twist plots huge plot twins
my boyfriend has an eight inch dick and
it doesn't even feel good it just hurts
only reason when I'm with him is because
he has money I'm cheating on him with an
average ex he actually knows how to
please me
it's what what's he supposed to do
so what he's caked and he has a massive
dick yeah and she's like [__] this guy
give me the cake that hurts I need
someone who could actually please me or
knows how to actually please me that's
out of order that's out of order I've
got a few more all right come on my
daughter turned four yesterday but since
money a little funny we didn't tell her
oh my God
she won't know she'll skip to five yeah
five she won't have a clue she just
won't be able to wait for her birthday
in fact that's horrible
unbelievable yeah unbelievable money a
little funny yeah so we just didn't tell
her
they would have blocked all the presents
coming through the doors that's jokes
blocking my number knowing I have your
address is crazy to me
thank you
that's a definition of my Westfair
you're defining my fear I'll be through
fam
it's just like literally if I was like
talking to a tank yeah and she happened
to have my address yeah and I just
blocked it I just want to block people
yeah yeah because I can't I'll be
looking through the drapes every day
that was inside Madison now it's a door
knocks I don't know who it is
I'm terrified
that's jokes I'll never forget the time
my girlfriend blocked me for being a
thought and I was calling and texting
her from different numbers and she still
wouldn't answer so I came up with the
idea to wait a little while and text her
and say I'm coming to you as a woman and
I've been [__] with Dooney for a
minute now and I'm six months pregnant I
don't want to talk through the I don't
want to talk through text so can you
call me man she called me she called
that number so fast only for her to hear
me scream on the other end baby please
me please
swear
last one yesterday I asked my
kindergartener what she was what she did
in school and she said nothing then
later I went on Instagram and her
teacher had her posted up with a
crocodile
oh
bro that's nuts
Instagram had a picture of her with a
crocodile oh babe what do you do in
school today not literally nothing I
couldn't see my baby
on my teacher's Instagram
facts someone's getting fined first of
all why was her first point of call to
go to the teachers
what kind of school is this [__] nose
awesome guys thank you very very much
for hanging with us today that was a
good one
um I'm trying to make these these maths
of Recaps of shorts possible but I can't
help it yeah yeah the juice so this is
why there's chapters bro
there's too much juice that's why Champs
if you don't like it skip it but also
don't don't yeah yeah also don't because
it's Saucy but anyway guys as always uh
if you want to watch more head on over
to patreon.com shits and gigs and um
without any further Ado level of love
[Music]
good